[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in rich eisen the host of
the nfl network host of the rich eisen
show that follows this one uh who's your
comeback player of the year picked there
oh dan i if you don't mind i just want
to make sure we're clear that uh i'm not
on with you
you're on with me right now oh okay
program
just want to just get this out and you
appreciate it might be awkward might be
awkward way to start but i just want to
make sure you understand uh you're on
with me right now my bad my bad my bad
uh your comeback player of the year it
is
smartass patrick beverly i don't know um
i i'll go with michael thomas um you
know i heard you guys talking on the way
in
um and um so of course at a red light um
i texted both paulie and uh
and fritz um that michael thomas is my
guy can't guard mike um is
clearly in line to be comeback player of
the year i i know mccaffrey you you guys
were talking about mccaffrey and then
you know you you said it right like
we're waiting for him just to come back
within a single season when he's already
out like that would be great
if he could just come back from injury
within the season in which he's injured
that has been a problem for him so i i
i know that a lot of people are are
wondering how the saints look with sean
payton gone
and um and obviously jameis winston back
coming from a knee injury but i'll take
can't guard mike
also it seems like everybody on staff at
nfl network has buffalo representing the
afc overwhelming unanimous it's almost i
think how does buffalo not make the
super bowl
well i mean just where
i guess in the way that they they had
last season uh end where a game
comes down to a clock management or
a bounce of the ball and it just doesn't
go their way and we talk about
how this franchise is snake bit
from you know scott norwood all the way
to the present day i mean that that's
that's what it seems like
uh would be the only way for this season
to end uh
for the bills that uh
that leaves us all with a little bit of
egg on our faces
because you look i mean sometimes
the simplest
path is is the right one for all of us
who are predicted don't make it tougher
than it needs to be when you've got an
mvp caliber quarterback
and weapons galore adding more players
through the draft on both sides of the
ball von miller now
in the locker room
as kind of the the og whispering the way
it should be done to all these kids who
might need that help for the final 13
seconds if their
coach doesn't squibb it you know like
that's the that's the
the path forward i think for the bills
and that's why i took them to win the
super bowl
is there another team that compares to
the chiefs as far as
varying degrees of prediction that they
could go to the super bowl or not make
the playoffs
i get i think yeah i think i think green
bay is that team dan um i think a lot of
people are
are looking that uh at the packers and
wondering where the offense is coming
from
uh when when rogers might have an off
day
um and when he has a great day
will somebody separate will he just be
one of those quarterbacks that's looking
for a guy to separate from a defense
that's wallpapering
uh on an offense that uh they know might
be coming because devonte adams isn't
there
um or the defense is as good as it's
been there in a long time and the coach
is a 13-win machine and rogers can win
his third mvp in a row certainly if the
offense looks the same way without
devonte adams i i i hear packers not
making it and i hear packers in the
super bowl
i i didn't understand aaron rodgers
approach where he was
somewhat critical of these receivers
during training camp but he's not
playing in these preseason games to be
with these receivers i mean it's one
thing to be in practice but he should
have been in games i think
to help them out like understand
game-like situations and i'm sure that
it's it's dangerous to do this
but i think he's got to be fair to these
wide receivers they're trying to figure
this out and do it in real time and
somebody's got to replace devante adams
aaron could have helped out i thought a
little bit your reaction to rogers
calling them out it was out of character
but i think he he definitely felt he
needed to do it i think he's got his
finger squarely on the pulse and the
players uh on his team that i've had
from aaron jones to aj dillon and
anybody else tanyan
uh will tell you that he is one of the
most
even including towards jordan love when
we were all in the media assuming he
wasn't
being the most you know
openly uh there wasn't much of a
mentorship program going on there um
that he is in fact doing that behind the
scenes which is why i thought it was out
of character for him to go out and
basically tell these guys hey you need
to be in the right spot you need to have
your head in a swivel you need to make
these catches and practice what i'm
throwing to you otherwise you won't be
out on the field i think he felt
compelled to do it uh either that or he
was sipping that tea dan um
yeah
is that how you pronounce it ayahuasca
okay
were you would you do it would you try
it as a journalist as a just because for
for the gig is that what you're saying
no let's say you were doing a story on
aaron rodgers yes
and you were going to go visit him to do
a sit down one one-on-one yeah but he
said
okay you got to do like to be on my
level you have to try iowa
are you are you asking me if i do some
gonzo journalism yes when it comes down
to it okay um last question for you
before i give you my answer do i have to
go home like will i go because my kids
don't care what dad does at work when i
go home you're at a hotel
in green
i'm out i'm out of it you're safe i'm
hot
[Music]
i don't know if you want it i think the
uh the results might vary but i don't
know if you want that yeah i don't know
apparently i'll be better at my job
with the rest of the team here you know
i mean i'll have a more enlightened way
of looking at things i might finally get
past
that emmy time you know i might finally
get there i don't know maybe i'll try it
well aaron did say that
he's better teammate he's a better lover
uh you know all the things that i'm
looking for in my quarterback because i
don't know the last time you went
patrick mahomes good lover
i don't know
it's in omaha
that is definitely uh
uh i'll i'll leave you with this yes uh
rams more likely to make the super bowl
or not make the playoffs make the super
bowl absolutely okay
no question about it i mean why
obviously
we've got to whenever having these
conversations pre-season or right before
seasons
barring injury is the caveat but i mean
what a what a deep roster i mean
and
adding bobby wagner behind aaron i don't
think anybody really has
landed and sat with the idea that the
best linebacker arguably of
our current generation right now all
right removing the ray lewis is from the
equation but bobby wagner is going to
have a bust in canton
we are placing him in between jalen
ramsey and right behind aaron donald i
don't believe we've realized the full
impact of this and i think alan robinson
will be a terrific compliment to the
rest of that offense they should win the
division and and some considerable deep
playoff run for the rams that's the way
i'm looking at it great to talk to you
thank you for allowing me to share this
moment with you rich you're welcome dan
is all i can say all right you're
welcome that's rich eisen of the nfl
network
kind enough to let me share the stage
with him